hi everyone and welcome to Nintendo's
digital event at e3 this year we wanted
to do something different to celebrate
what it means to be a Nintendo fail
today you'll meet many of the talented
Nintendo teams working hard to deliver
great games and hear some of our big III
news with more to be shared throughout
the show while I've changed out of my
fire flower suit for now Mario is still
close to my heart you may recognize this
as what mr. owada used earlier to defeat
my me fighter and super smash brothers
now I'll say there's no way he beats me
without resorting to a little magic and
in fact I'm right that's exactly what he
did because this is no ordinary toy this
is one of the first in a new line of
products Nintendo has a development
called amiibo and only on Nintendo
systems will you be able to enjoy all
the different experiences in this toys
to life category along with amiibo both
Disney infinity and Skylanders trap team
have unique features and functionality
that can only be found on Wii U there's
a special chip that's embedded in every
figure any Wii U system will recognize
the figures by touching them on the Wii
U gamepad and when that happens they
spring to life in compatible games in
cool new ways when you touch amiibo to
the gamepad the characters data is
downloaded into the game you're playing
and it's also a two-way street we can
send information back to the figure so
in other words your figures data changes
as you play which opens the door for
various new gameplay possibilities
for example your own figure with its own
unique stats and fighting style will not
only appear but also evolve as a fighter
and super smash brothers on Wii U in
fact super smash brothers for Wii U will
indeed be the first game to support
amoeba in other words this holiday were
not only releasing the game you've been
waiting for but also amiibo that
literally gives you new ways to play as
you saw in my battle with mr. wada when
you use an amiibo and super smash
brothers for Wii U that character will
appear as a fighter in the game and
compete in battles developing its own
unique attributes and skills you can
fight against them yourself have them
score off against other amoeba they can
even join you and fight on the same team
but super smash brothers is just the
start amiibo play is also being prepared
right now for a number of other Nintendo
games one of those is a game many of you
are already playing mario kart 8 we'll
have more details on that and other game
soon I'm guessing you've got a lot of
questions but there's much more to cover
in this digital event today so I'm going
to ask you to do this when we're done
here at any time you can catch Nintendo
of America's own bill Trenton who's
hosting a dedicated amiibo video that
goes into a little more detail so be
sure to find him at Nintendo calm or the
nintendo youtube channel
you